ارهاق وتعب واكتئاب والنهايه انتحار
يخلصني من هذه الحياه هذه كانت اخر رساله
كتبها نجم البوب الكوري الجنوبي
قبل انهائه حياته في ظاهره تكررت كثيرا
بين الفنانين الشباب في كوريا الجنوبيه
خلال السنوات الماضيه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هذا الشاب اليافع الشهير في كوريا
الجنوبيه هو مومبين نجم الكيبوب وعضو فريق
استرو البالغ من العمر 25 عاما عثر عليه
ميتا في منزله وفاه مومبين تم تاكيدها في
بيان رسمي نشر عبر صفحات الفرقه على مواقع
التواصل ومن دون ذكر سبب الوفاه في مقاله
صحف كوريه ان الوفاه كانت انتحارا ونجحت
الشرطه الكوريه الجنوبيه ذلك ايضا الا ان
التحقيقات ما زالت جاريه
وفيات نجوم الفن الكوري انتشرت كثيرا في
الاونه الاخيره وكلها ربطت بحالات انتحار
ففي عام 2021 عثر على جثه الفنانه الكوريه
الشابه سونغيو جونغ في العاصمه سيول وسط
ترجيحات بانهائها لحياتها
[موسيقى]
معظم حالات الانتحار بين النجوم الكوريين
كانت لفنانين شباب لم تتجاوز اعمارهم
الثلاثين عاما وسط غموض يلف الحوادث
تقارير كشفت ان الوكالات الكوريه تفرض
قيودا صارمه على الشباب الملتحقين بها من
التحكم في مظهرهم واكلهم وطريقه عيشهم
وكذلك تفاصيل حياتهم الاجتماعيه وينتهي
بهم المطاف باستبدالهم فور بلوغهم سن
الثلاثين
وبالتالي حرمانهم من الحياه الاجتماعيه
الطبيعيه تكوين الاصدقاء او حتى الذهاب
الى المدارس لذلك هي ليست بالمسيره السهله
هي ليست في المسيره المليئه بالحب
والمليئه بالنجاحات والسعاده بل هناك
الكثير من الضغوط والصعوبات التي واجهها
هؤلاء الفنانين على على الصعيد الشخصي
بالنسبه لهم
في عام 2017 استفاقت كوريا على خبر انتحار
المغني كيم جونغ هيون عضوي فرقه شان
الشهيره عن عمر لم يتجاوز 27 عاما تاركا
وراءه رساله قال فيها ان الاكتئاب تغلب
عليه وعام 2019 انتحرت سولي نجمه موسيقى
البوب البالغه من العمر 25 عاما بعد ان
عانت من التنمر على صفحات التواصل وبعد
حوالي سته اسابيع فقط انتحرت صديقتها
جوهرا عن عمر 28 عاما بسبب الاكتئاب كذلك
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه سلطت الضوء
على هذه الظاهره مؤكده انتحار 30 شخصا من
بين نجوم الصف الاول بكوريا الجنوبيه
قائله ان تعامل الوكالات مع النجوم كان
عاملا رئيسيا في اقدامهم على الانتحار
[موسيقى]
يتم رصد العديد من المشاهير وهم اطفال ولا
يتم تعليمهم مهارات حياتيه قيمه ولكن فقط
كيفيه الغناء والرقص الوضع اسوء بالنسبه
للمشاهير حيث يهتم الجمهور اكثر بكل
التفاصيل في حياتهم
ظاهره الانتحار في هذا البلد الاسيوي لا
تنحصر فقط على المشاهير فقوريا الجنوبيه
دائما ما تكون في المراكز الاولى في
معدلات الانتحار عالميا وكاله الاحصاءات
الكوريه الجنوبيه كشفت عن ارتفاع معدل
الانتحار لكل 100 الف شخص من الشباب في
العشرينات بسبب كورونا عام 2021
واكدت الاحصائيات ان النساء والمراهقات
ومن هم في سن العشرين هم الفئه الغالبه
التي تقبل على الانتحار بغض النظر عن
مكانتهم الاجتماعيه